[Music]
all right ted thank you for that well as
we suffer through these sweltering heats
staying hydrated of course is very
important and critical current
guidelines listen to this say men need
about 15 cups a day of water and for
women that number is about 11 cups of
water and remember this is we're talking
about water not alcohol but experts say
this can vary according to size and of
course how active you are and what
medication you might be on so make sure
that you take a note of that next time
you're filling up that water bottle and
of course if you're not a big fan of
plain water coffee tea and flavored
waters can also hydrate you now even
though these are just temporary fixes
just think a bit of this as a short term
fix your body still receives some
hydration benefits now some things to
keep in mind here these are some things
that even i do here when it's really
really hot outside fruits and vegetables
can also help specifically we're talking
about cucumbers celery watermelon and of
course strawberries you can't forget
about those strawberries